تنظر إلى الذكاء الذي لا يمكنهم القيام به
وبدون الولايات المتحدة لا يمكنهم العمل بدونها
الولايات المتحدة: صحيح أن هناك أصواتاً في إسرائيل تقول
يجب أن نكون أكثر استقلالية و نقلل من
أعتقد أن هذا الاعتماد وتقليل الألفة قد رفعته
الالتزام الأمريكي تجاه إسرائيل كما تم التعبير عنه
سيبقى نفس ج بايدن في السنوات القادمة لا
يعرف ما يتحدث عنه ولا يفهم ما يجري
في البلدان
[موسيقى]
نما العهد ضد إسرائيل في عمود هندسي وديني
جمهور ناقد للغاية ولا يرى في إسرائيل رصيدًا
استراتيجية ولا تعتبر إسرائيل دولة حائزة بشكل عام
بريت أمينة هات لدينا كارثة في كل مرة
عندما أرحل لا أعلم كيف سأنتهي منك
اليوم
منجم أنا خائف من الحبير شراي إلى سيميلاك
فتاة الثلاجة
أنا فقط أخاطر بحياتي كل يوم
الرصاص فوق الرأس وأنا أحميك وأحميك
ولكلهم هناك شخص آخر ثلاجته فقط
يوجد هنا شخص آخر لم يستلم راتب أحد الأشخاص
ولم يستلم منك راتبا ولكم جزيل الشكر
نفهم أننا إذا لم نحقق الإنجاز وأنا
أسمع قليلا
مخللات وقليل من هذا والقليل من الناس لديهم بالفعل
انتقاد وربما الهدف لن يتحقق
يجب أن يتحقق إذا لم يتحقق
سوف يعود لحم الخنزير إلى قوته بسرعة كبيرة، لا بد أن يكون كذلك
تم تحقيقه لثلاثة أسباب فقط
كلمة واحدة لأنه بخلاف ذلك سنثبت أننا نستطيع ذلك
الأعداء من حولنا ونقاط الضعف في الصورة
الإسرائيلي سوف يتعمق أكثر فأكثر وسيسبب لنا مشاكل
والشيء الثاني الأكبر بكثير هو ثقة الجمهور
بيتزال والشيء الثالث هو الثمن الذي دفعناه حتى الآن
أعلى سعر هائل منذ قيام الدولة
إسرائيل التي دفعنا ثمن هذه الحرب لا تستطيع ذلك
أن ننتهي بأقل من انتصار نتذكره جيدًا
كثيرا مسألة المعدات الشخصية في هذه الأيام
أول القتال كان ينقص تجاه الأم
تم الاحتفال بالشتاء بشكل مختلف
لفصل الشتاء